have you ever talked to anybody about
your fertility or going through this
process like oh and I went to a
fertility clinic in Nigeria uh-huh and
she told me over there that I had one
egg hey my 90 day fans fam it's Malizia
here and just a few I'm going to give
you a quick rundown of all the
highlights from the latest episode of
happily ever after but first we have to
get into the biggest must-see moment
which goes to Angela who took a trip to
her gynecologist here in the states to
check on that one egg all right so a lot
of pressure here out Lord bigger than
Michaels penis Angela keep watching keep
watching
has anybody ever told you how to fibroid
is that the painful thing it's like a
little tumor that can grow in your
uterus I already take this out okay all
right you can sit up okay okay
okay so so there is no sister like we
talked about that's a good thing okay
and one more thing yeah it's confirmed I
don't have an egg I don't see any signs
of that no all of Angelo's jokes aside
this was actually a really tough episode
for her on top of dealing with her
mother being really sick the doctor
basically told her in a nice way that
the chances of her getting pregnant on
her own at 54 are zero we knew that but
what's more concerning is that Angela
also learned during her doctor's visit
that what she thought was a period could
actually be uterine cancer which is
really scary here I thought my biggest
worry was not to be able to tow to maybe
for Michael but now my biggest worry is
I could have cancer
that's terrifying for anyone even though
she didn't receive great news from her
doctor
I spoke with Angela last week and she
revealed to me that she is still
actively trying to get pregnant believe
it or not it's only fair you know I do
everything possible because she asked me
for much and you know it's gonna be a
lot of money maybe it's gonna be this
method if that means Tim his mom had
because I really loved his mom by you
and he just deserves one one way or
another but there will not be no
releasing him to other women
right cuz that is I mean we've seen some
other people talk about that option
that's something that is off limits for
you yeah I know that's know if I do
everything possible I can in Michael but
then they don't mean that he'll come for
it there will be none for the women
Angela loves her son cake okay but I
can't argue with what she said I feel
her same same here sweetie same here
next up Sinjin and Tonya moved out
Italians mom's backyard and into their
new place but there's only one problem
actually there are two problems neither
Sinjin nor Tonya have a job during the
episode
Sinjin rebel Becky has an interview at a
local bar coming up but Tonya is not too
happy about it considering the fact that
Sinjin likes a drink a lot so I'm
nervous so you're gonna come home drunk
every night and then you're gonna tell
me Oh what babe I just had a couple
drink
where I come for God I didn't drink
anymore anybody else times you lost your
phone the time I've lost shirts
relationships motorcycles lost it for
three days and he didn't even get by
okay you have the money back finally
just to Colt to go meet her Brazilian au
pair friends and it didn't go well but
on the bright side we finally learned
who banessa is my niece I call you all
the time who is that girl she's just a
friend
uh-huh I've been friends with Nessa
since I was going through my divorce
from Larissa we started talking online
about my troubled marriage and she was
there to help me through it jess has
never met Vanessa but I think she thinks
I'm having an affair with her but
vanessa is just a friend if you hurt my
friend yeah I got a problems with us a
big problem if you ask me it seems like
Vanessa is the one that Colt should be
dating anyway 90 day fans fam we have so
much to look forward to next week
Karina and Paul land in America Larissa
finds out about Colts new relationship
with Jess and Angela and Michael plead
with Scylla to be the witness at their
nigerian wedding make sure you stick
with these seeds to stay updated on all
the latest from our guilty pleasure all
right my 90 day fans film Wow I'll see
you next time
[Music]